jennifer lopez is getting candid about
her second chance at love with ben
affleck
[Music]
that's right the 52 year old actress
reflects on her rekindled relationship
with the actor in the latest issue of
people telling the mag quote i feel so
lucky and happy and proud to be with him
i'm thrilled j-lo adds it's a beautiful
love story that we got a second chance
but their love story initially came with
some reservations you'll recall the pair
first started dating in 2002 and became
one of the most famous celebrity couples
in the world affectionately known as
benefer they got engaged in 2003 but by
2004 they called off their wedding it
was my first kind of heartbreak fast
forward to 2021
and they reconnected but jen admits they
had a little bit of fear about publicly
sharing their relationship again quote
before we kind of put our relationship
out there and we were naive and it got a
little trampled and that hesitation is a
topic ben opened up to howard stern
about in december and even the
relationship now i i see you're with
jennifer that even brings more attention
to you you've been through that scene
where you're constantly in the tablet
was there hesitation on your part to say
just you know i can't go through this
again you know uh it crossed my mind for
sure that
well look my response to my children is
the highest responsibility i have so
nothing i can't do anything that's
that's painful or destructive to them if
i can help that being said you know um i
know that my life affects them was it
because it was so public and we wanted
to know every single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help it was like
a tough one for me for whatever reason
for many reasons despite any second
thoughts the couple is excited to be
back together but this time they've got
a different strategy now that they're
wiser with more life experience jen
explains quote we were both like wow
we're so happy and we don't want any of
that to come into play again we're at
different places in our lives we have
kids now and we have to be very
conscious of those things we're so
protective because it is such a
beautiful time for all of us it just
turned out to be something really
magical as for ben and jen's famous
friends well they're in full support of
their romance like ben's bestie matt
damon it's great
it's it's wonderful and i'm i'm just
happy to see uh see my friend really
happy and jen's co-star from selena
constance marie you know what honey if
it works
i say do it you know love is love is
love is love and
she loves love so go for it you know but
the million dollar question will that
love lead to wedding bells
i'm ready last month a source told et
the pair is madly in love and will
eventually get engaged and get this in
november the marry me star had this to
say about the possibility of getting
hitched again you know me i'm a romantic
i always have been i've been married a
few times i still believe in happily
ever after for sure
you